[Music]
we're trying to do this fast what a week
for trailers for you know the other day
and now the mother of all trailers the
trailer to end all trailers man we're
talking about the last Jedi Sun dropped
at Star Wars Celebration and I was
watching it on the YouTube livestream
Stover's like um boom they just put up
the trailer and then shortly thereafter
it's gone everywhere in the internet so
we're going to watch it together man it
would be a good time I've already
watched it I'll be honest a couple times
I like it very much it doesn't tell us
much the [ __ ] it tells me enough man I
can't [ __ ] wait I'm gonna wet my
whistle a little bit this movie directed
by Rian Johnson yeah he was over here at
the house I think once we did an episode
of smoothie makers together you can go
listen to its Monica stop come great guy
boy he [ __ ] shot the [ __ ] out of this
Star Wars pictured a looper boy no
longer looper boy looper man has now
become the next Jedi which as we here in
the trailer is the last Jedi was that
all means Luke sound like he's going bad
I don't know what the [ __ ] going on I
don't care I just want to [ __ ] see it
I'm so excited I got my framed Carrie
Fisher picture she sent this to me well
she didn't but her fan company sent this
to me when I was let me see this came
out something 10 years I've had this is
us 910 since 1979 almost 10 years old
I've had this thing you sleep sitting
next to my bed and then I kiss it at
night that night Star Wars posters I've
kissed prisons I was a huge characters
your pen and I printed lay on the sheets
toner sheets oh I hate to tell you what
I did with those um but but this ladies
and gentlemen is historic moment we get
to see our first glimpse at the last
Jedi I'm excited as it [ __ ] gets man
ice-type look I'll be honest with you I
soiled my shorts what shorts you ask why
these Jay and Silent Bob's sure
son to any man right there look at this
where do you get those lootcrate look at
that
J saw by Blue Creek mediums I'll never
fit in these [ __ ] they sent him to me
tryout lootcrate calm folks it's an
amazing [ __ ] service sign up for as
they send you [ __ ] free [ __ ] all time
and those Jay and Silent Bob panty is
going to be in a box sooner or later
good loot crate's calm slash SModcast
yes I'm fitting in a little at okay man
I got the trailer it's lined up we're
going to watch the [ __ ] out of this so
I've seen it now I'm you can tell I've
seen them all sweaty and I've got I
can't do this long because I got to go
introduce Joe casada who is introducing
Stan Lee on a panel on Stan Lee at the
Paley Center I'm just now I'm just
[ __ ] name-dropping look at look at my
big I know a lot of people dick that I
pull out of my pants
but in any event what a nerd day for me
I'm going to watch this with you and my
hell over the Paley Center and [ __ ]
see Joe Kassadin Stanley
thank God because things politically in
the world are so weird I'd rather stay
right here in a galaxy far far away
let's look at this [ __ ] mind you I've
been a fan since I was seven saw Star
Wars in a movie theater when I was seven
years old I was in kinda the last Star
Wars movie that JJ did force awakens
I played the voice of a stormtrooper and
stuff when when they were attacked when
the first one the first order was
attacking Madam's castle and then the
resistance showed up we called him the
belly and when I was kids and the Empire
but any event we know we know the story
here let's check in now this movie last
time we saw Luke Skywalker he was on a
cliff and he was about to say some [ __ ]
his daughter was like I give you your
dick back dad and then suddenly credits
that happened at the end of force
awakens this trailer takes place last
Jedi shortly thereafter it seems that
some training is taking place let's dive
in let's let's watch the [ __ ] of this
shall we
mmm-hmm happy Friday kids you know my
daughter's going to Coachella today with
a bunch of kids going out to the desert
and stuff and whoop it up listen to me
this is my Coachella right here thank
you Star Wars and Kathy and and and Ryan
everybody who is responsible for for
droppin this trailer today this is my
Coachella my Coachella there you go all
right here we go
and my Easter here we go press and play
one two three
that music where are we what is this man
looks like it's coming in so a deer a
female deer ray a drop of Golden Sun man
she's out of breath and she's got her
hands on the ground what is she doing
she's learning the force I thought for a
second maybe Luca force-choked they're
gonna do to hear that you're lovely
look at this beautiful island man they
love water in these Star Wars movies now
now it's all about the water back in the
day just breathe
that's what I was doing I was watching
this trailer that's what they're telling
us just breathe look at the [ __ ]
force on hand and then cut the black
come on go dick tease me oh [ __ ] what do
I see
I see my [ __ ] future I see the
resistance does that bacala is that I
don't know I see what looks like a smash
kylo Ren helmet right there
[ __ ] kylo Ren he [ __ ] killed Han Solo
spoilers and [ __ ] I hope she would kill
the [ __ ] out of him in this movie and
what's this some books whose love is
that whose hand is that
and look some trainings going on man
there's the last Jedi is Luke and he's
watching legs you fight with the pocket
like great a man and there we go you
know what Star Wars is his [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey oh my god
holy [ __ ] there look at this [ __ ] they
just attacked the [ __ ] rubble basic
[ __ ] my man Poe Dameron yeah [ __ ] yes
we saw a piece of his vision remember in
the last movie with a [ __ ] kylo Ren
show up and [ __ ] like that look at all
that star worthy nothing what the [ __ ]
does that mean
tell me for oh my god I'm so [ __ ]
excited man this looks like this title
treatments should return the Jedi when I
was kid before that was Revenge of the
Jedi [ __ ] this noise let's watch this
[ __ ] again oh my god how wonderful is
that
you know look is it Thor know we kind of
know what to expect from a Star Wars
movie but we don't know what to expect
from this Star Wars movie this [ __ ]
looks like religion I think looper boy
pulled that looper man Luke burr man has
pulled it [ __ ] off Ryan like a brick
in my [ __ ] face man here we go we're
gonna watch a [ __ ] one more time one
more time when I was a kid I was at
Great Adventure Six Flags and we went on
this ride called the Calypso me and my
brother and my cousin and [ __ ] and it
was the end of the night and so they
kept at the end of the ride we kept
going one more time one more time and
the dude would start the ride again we'd
all go through the ride after doing that
three times my brother [ __ ]
projectile vomited all over the Calypso
car man was sloshing back and forth and
[ __ ] my cousin was trying to climb out
of it when I was crazy in any event that
then one more [ __ ] time let's do this
man
let's watch this try to take and try to
figure out what's going on however you
agents came out to you say
[Applause]
what is what's going on there Luke must
be training Lucasfilm AOL TV now love
seeing those words that is the words
that tell the happy childhood that and
can't breathe I will tell me what to do
cock-knocker
work today thank God thank God it was
the last day that now faculty staff is
needed now my shirt is a footnote the
[ __ ] for da support senator give me
more give me some more [ __ ] business
that that that looks like got to be less
I'm feeling that sleigh I know that the
busted kylo Ren helmet for sure and and
then my man was I don't get it the
bookshelf not here ad what's going on
with these books what is that sign of
the Jedi they have a symbol that a logo
to they Brandon of the chest like Batman
sleeping shop would it be decent man
is there no green screen right here I
see a doubt from the distance for
bringing more out access
at f/4 all I check then back BBA looking
blowing [ __ ] up out of that [ __ ]
Escalade Imran everyone's running so for
the modern day moving up others were
running look at an army of kylo Ren good
night to Brent
they're battling in the stars to Jedi
and tired this [ __ ] you done man you
kidding me
you see that [ __ ] sequence you see
did you see the war and face did you see
did you see did you see it all did you
see one pose hangers being attacked and
then a bb-8 had to stop look like
[ __ ] seal Tim ricke dropped in I
can't wait to see this movie man what a
[ __ ] week
there's look at me I'm sweating I
believe from my faith has been rewarded
for years I've been a massive fan of
this woman in her work and a massive fan
of the Star Wars franchise and I'm gonna
get to go dive into it again man the
fountain uses returned kids it's right
there man spread that trailer around and
tell people it's coming what's left like
now I got to live now I gotta let you
know there's some political unrest in
the world I need people to put their
[ __ ] aside until at least December so I
can see this picture because I'm going
to be able to see this one early I got
any friendlies over there anymore so
what the [ __ ] I'm never going to be able
to see this era I got to see it like
everybody else on opening day so heavens
please stop fighting wherever you're
fighting and stuff there's only one war
we should all be thinking about Star
Wars last Jedi Sun thanks for hanging
out I'm gonna go talk to Stan Lee and
jokes out that's right I'm name-dropping
[Music]
you
[Music]